deutschland schließt grenzen wegen des
corona virus bleiben die schlagbäume zu
mehreren ländern nur für waren und
pendler oben
wenn die kultur pause macht nach berlin
schließt auch bayern cafés kinos und
sporthalle hamburg untersagt alle
veranstaltungen fußball-em auf der kippe
die uefa will offenbar das turnier wegen
der pandemie verschieben
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend ich begrüße
sie zu unserem sonntags
nachrichtenüberblick erstmals ohne die
kollegin den kollegen vom sport die
zeiten in denen ein virus das leben
aller verändert sind ebenso im kampf
gegen das corona virus greift
deutschland jetzt offenbar zu immer
drastischeren maßnahmen in minister
seehofer will gleich grenzschließungen
begründen
demnach sollen ab morgen früh um 8 uhr
die grenzen zu mehreren nachbarländern
geschlossen werden
betroffen sind die grenzen zu frankreich
der schweiz und zu österreich und
ebenfalls morgen wird auch die grenze zu
dänemark dichtgemacht die dänen hatten
ihre seite der grenze bereits gestern
geschlossen
ja aus unserem europa ohne grenzen
werden nun also wieder eher
nationalstaaten die sich abzuschotten
versuchen um menschenleben zu retten
werfen wir einen blick an die westliche
und südliche grenze zu jürgen bollmann
und eva schiller eva sie sind in kehl am
rhein an der grenze zu frankreich die
schließung wird das leben der menschen
hier im grenzgebiet ja mächtig verändern
oder ja absolut hier an der deutsch
französischen grenze wird schon
stichprobenartig kontrolliert aber wie
diese teilweise grenzschließung wie
diese festen grenzkontrollen morgen
aussehen sollen das wissen noch nichtmal
die polizeibeamten sie warten noch auf
ansagen aus berlin
aber fest steht es wird ein jäher
einschnitt ein historischer tag für eine
regierung die in den letzten jahrzehnten
ja sehr sehr eng zusammengewachsen ist
diese symbolische grenze zwischen
deutschland und frankreich die waffe die
menschen im alltag eigentlich überhaupt
nicht mehr spürbar
wir hören aber aus regierungskreisen
dass zumindest berufspendler wohl weiter
passieren dürfen
ein grund für diese grenzkontrollen
liegt auch in der unterbindung von
hamsterkäufen die menschen hier in kehl
auf deutscher seite berichten in den
letzten tagen schon von
versorgungsengpässen jürgen wollmann sie
sind bei bad reichenhall ändern
österreichischen grenze auch da sind
sicher alle von dem schritt überrascht
worden wurde ja auch das wird hier einen
tiefen einschnitt geben mein eindruck
ist damit hat nun wirklich keiner
gerechnet auch wenn die nachbarländer
schon angefangen hatten die grenzen zu
schließen ja auch österreich so richtig
vorbereitet ist der glaube ich keiner
und man muss ja sehen die grenzübergänge
zwischen deutschland und österreich das
sind ja sehr wichtige wirtschafts
verbindungen dabei geht es ja nicht nur
darum waren zu liefern sondern das
produzierende gewerbe das ist doch sehr
vernetzt untereinander mit zulieferungen
und vielen anderen dingen also mein
eindruck ist die pendler hier die
hoffnung jetzt sehr darauf dass es für
sie ausnahmen geben wird es gibt viele
österreicher die hier in bayern arbeiten
und umgekehrt und die firmen
lebensmittelgeschäfte aber auch fabriken
hoffen natürlich dass es ausnahmen für
den warenverkehr geben wird was wir aber
auch noch gehört haben ist dass es heute
eine krisensitzung der bayerischen
landesregierung gab und es ist damit zu
rechnen dass in bayern morgen noch
einmal das öffentliche leben mit
maßnahmen drastisch heruntergefahren
wird
tiefe einschnitte vielen dank jürgen
danke eva ein möglicher grund für die
geplanten grenzschließungen die zahl der
infektionen bei uns im land steigt
weiter an nach angaben der
amerikanischen johns hopkins universität
liegt sie inzwischen bei 4585 inzwischen
gibt es elf todesfälle
besonders betroffen sind weiterhin die
bundesländer nordrhein westfalen und
bayern
dort gibt es immer mehr fälle ganz
deutschland muss einschränkungen
hinnehmen
volker duschek berichtet tische rücken
am wannsee auch in diesem berliner
ausflugslokal muss der abstand zwischen
den gästen jetzt mindestens 1 meter 50
betragen sonst es schluss mit ausschank
für gastronom steffen kirchner wird der
start in die saison zum schmerzhaften
hindernislauf
die die lager sind gefüllt kassen leer
mitarbeiter stehen parat wir haben das
team aufgebaut für den saisonstart der
letztendlich wahrscheinlich bei diesen
guten wetter heute gewesen wäre sogar
wohl auch darauf gehofft haben und wir
brauchen dich für die zuschüsse wir
brauchen ganz klar kurzfristiges geld um
entscheidungen zu treffen
das heißt auch dieses thema kurzarbeit
wird wahrscheinlich gar nicht zum zuge
kommen für uns weil wir kündigen müssen
reservisten bitte melden
verteidigungsministerin
kramp-karrenbauer will sie in
bundeswehrkrankenhäusern einsetzen
wir planen auf allen ebenen so dass wir
alle kritischen bereiche sicher abdecken
könnten auch das was an amtshilfe auf
uns zukommt mindestabstand auch beim
beten im berliner dom wird heute bewusst
vor leeren stuhlreihen gepredigt der
gottesdienst wird per internet in die
welt übertragen
komplett ausgefallen ist dagegen der
fischmarkt in hamburg das erste mal seit
300 jahren blaustern blüte gegen trübe
gedanken die sorge vor weiteren
quarantänevorschriften sie treibt sicher
viele nach draußen frühlingswetter auch
in hannover ein paar stunden sonne um
mal durchzuschnaufen und mais im freien
und draußen und kriegt ein bisschen
abstand von den ganzen meldungen
wir sind uns der situation schon auch
bewusst das ist auch klar aber es gibt
es geht weiter also und man versucht
eben wie gesagt das schöne zu genießen
die farben das wird die luft ist ja
fantastisch und soeben hat sich
bundesinnenminister seehofer zu den
drastischen maßnahmen geäußert die ab
morgen früh an den deutschen grenzen zu
frankreich österreich der schweiz und
dänemark gelten sollen mit dem ab morgen
stattfindenden grenzkontrollen werden
beschränkungen im grenzüberschreitenden
verkehr verbunden sein
ich weiß ja aber ausdrücklich darauf hin
dass der warenverkehr und der
grenzüberschreitende verkehr von
berufspendlern weiterhin möglich sein
werden ja soweit der innenminister klaus
brodbeck in berlin eigentlich wollte
sich deutschland ja mit den anderen
europäern auf gemeinsame maßnahmen
einigen
warum nun doch dieser deutsche allein
es ist kein ganz allein kann kein
totaler alleingang mache zumindest mit
frankreich bilateral verhandeln auch mit
der schweiz und österreich wohl
gesprochen aber die rasanz und die
aggressivität mit der sich das virus
ausbreitet hat 65 zum handeln gezwungen
seehofer hat mitgeteilt dass er
natürlich in abstimmung mit den
europäern handeln möchte die
europäischen
die europäische kommission ist bereits
informiert worden es gibt das sehen die
verfahren so vor ein notifizierung
schreiben das eben auch und die
kommission heute noch rausgehen soll in
dem über die verschärften
grenzkontrollen informiert wird das geht
auch an die also nicht nur liebe
nachbarn sondern auch alle anderen
europäischen eu-innenminister raus also
man ist versucht auf europäischer ebene
durchaus einen abgestimmten modus zu
halten aber offensichtlich ist das virus
schneller als viele unserer verfahren
vielen dank für die erklärung klaus
brodbeck und auch das öffentliche leben
unserer nachbarn in österreich ist
drastisch eingeschränkt das land müsse
auf notbetrieb runtergefahren werden so
bundeskanzler kurz die bürger dürften
nur noch aus drei gründen das haus
verlassen um zu arbeiten
zum einkauf von lebensmitteln und um
anderen menschen zu helfen
ab dienstag müssen restaurants
geschlossen bleiben
britta hilpert in wien sehr drastische
maßnahmen der regierung kurz wie sehr
steht das leben im land damit still
ab 0 uhr heute nacht tritt das corona
gesetz in kraft aber schon heute wurde
es in wien merklich stiller wenn man
auch mancher orts doch noch
frühlingsluft schnuppern wollte aber ab
morgen muss man dann eben gute gründe
haben um überhaupt auf der straße zu
sein für die arbeit für die versorgung
für die hilfe anderer und die polizei
darf das kontrollieren und sie darf auch
strafen verhängen wenn gruppen von mehr
als fünf personen sich weigern
auseinanderzugehen
man muss sich das mal vorstellen ab
morgen ist praktisch alles geschlossenen
schulen unis spiel sportplätze nicht
lebensnotwendige geschäfte ab dienstag
alle gaststätten
das wird in den nächsten wochen ein ganz
anderes land als das sonst so gesellige
österreich das sind 1
bitte in die persönliche freiheit die
man hier seit dem zweiten weltkrieg
nicht erlebt hat aber sie sind nötig
sagt die regierung kommt vielleicht auch
auf uns zu vielen dank britta hilpert in
wien die korona krise sorgt offenbar
auch für weitere verstimmungen zwischen
deutschland und den usa
hintergrund sind die bemühungen
schnellstmöglich einen impfstoff zu
entwickeln
führend dabei ist die tübinger firma
cure weg nun wurde bekannt die trump
regierung soll versucht haben die
forscher samt ihren bisherigen
ergebnissen mit geld nach amerika zu
locken wohl exklusiv zum nutzen der
us-bevölkerung pure weg betonte man
wolle eine weltweite lösung und keinen
impfstoff für einzelne staaten auch die
bundesregierung befindet sich in
gesprächen mit cure weg präsident trumps
einreise stopp für eu bürger führt
mittlerweile an vielen
nordamerikanischen flughäfen zu
chaotischen zuständen us bürger die aus
europa zurückkehren müssen bei der
einreise stundenlange wartezeiten über
sich ergehen lassen denn sie werden nur
ins land gelassen wenn sie zuvor einen
gesundheitscheck absolvieren
elmar theveßen sie wollen nur nach hause
tausende von amerikanern die per
flugzeug aus europa zurück kommen bis zu
sechs stunden wartezeit dicht gedrängt
den schlangen weil sie bei der einreise
untersucht werden müssen
die bundesbehörde völlig unvorbereitet
obwohl sie seit tagen von den massnahmen
wusste der gouverneur von illinois
wendet sich wütend an den präsidenten
per twitter das sei ja die einzige
kommunikationsform der aufmerksamkeit
schenke sie müssen was unternehmen jetzt
danach bekam ich einen anruf aus dem
weißen haus ein mitarbeiter schrie mich
an aber diese menschen stecken fest auf
engem raum hunderte genau das wollen wir
nicht inmitten einer pandemie überall im
land mehr schlangen an den mobilen
teststationen von denen viele vorzeitig
schließen müssen weil es weiterhin zu
wenige test packungen
im weißen haus wird die temperatur
gemessen bei den reportern
immerhin hat der us-präsident sich auf
das corona virus testen lassen ergebnis
negativ er muss sich kritische fragen
gefallen lassen weil er öffentlich wenig
vorbildhaft weiterhin geschüttelt
entspannen sie sich die leute strecken
die hand aus ein reflex aber
händeschütteln ist wirklich nicht gut
das stimmt
die großen vergnügungsparks in den usa
werden heute abend geschlossen sowie
zoos museen cafés und restaurants
oliver und elyse machen das aller beste
aus der situation liebe in zeiten von
krone um die verbreitung des virus
einzudämmen hat auch spanien den
notstand ausgerufen
ab morgen früh gilt im ganzen land eine
ausgangssperre
regierungschef sanchez kündigte an dass
bürger ihr haus nur für die arbeit oder
lebensnotwendige besorgungen verlassen
dürfen
das land mit knapp 47 millionen
bewohnern ist nach italien das am
stärksten betroffene land in europa in
bayern hat der demokratie der korona
epidemie offenbar eindrucksvoll getrotzt
bei der kommunalwahl stimmten mehr
bürger ab als vor sechs jahren
der grund deutlich mehr - war das
wahllokal aber vielmehr wählten per
brief bürgermeister landräte stadt und
gemeinderäte sowie kreistage wurden neu
bestimmt die fußball europameisterschaft
wird wegen des corona wie es
voraussichtlich nicht in diesem sommer
stattfinden
nach zdf informationen wird der
europäische verband uefa vorschlagen den
wettbewerb zu verschieben mindestens um
ein paar monate möglicherweise sogar um
ein ganzes jahr
die einzelheiten jetzt von marcus h der
käufer und ihrem präsidenten aleksander
ceferin läuft die zeit davon
die em wie geplant auszutragen
mittlerweile wohl illusorisch daher will
die uefa am dienstag allen beteiligten
im europäischen fussball vorschlagen
die em zu verschieben besondere umstände
erforderten besondere maßnahmen so wie
ich höre will die uefa zwei alternativen
anbieten
die bevorzugte variante die em im sommer
2021 zu spielen dafür bedarf es der
zustimmung der fifa sollte die sich quer
stellen plant die uefa mit den zeitraum
spätherbst frühen winter diesen jahres
fifa präsident gianni infantino will im
sommer 2021 eigentlich seine neue klub
wm ausrichten er muss den uefa plänen
zustimmen
der ball liegt jetzt bei der fifa und
wir haben zum schluss nur noch das
wetter über den norden ziehen
wolkenfelder es gibt aber kaum schauer
nach süden hin wird es immer sonniger
bei neun bis 20 grad
der frühling ist also da das war es von
uns ich danke ihnen für ihre
aufmerksamkeit verabschiede mich bis
morgen und wünsche ihnen noch einen
schönen sonntag